this is this is what i'm uh uh getting
from what you guys are saying okay
uh military industrial complex check we
don't disagree
most of the wars started that we didn't
need to go to they were not necessary
fine check 90 let's put it out you can
say 100
fine they were not necessary let's go
there the only area for me with this
that concerns me that i think the
argument
uh uh
needs to be sold in a better way is you
have to believe that there are certain
people worried
and and fearing the next possible
you know hitler that decides to go out
there and do something i think your
argument has to touch on that a little
bit to know that here's how we would
handle that person i'm i'm a
strategist i'm a defense guy i'm an
insurance guy i'm a financial guy so
it's always a defensive strategy in case
of a market crash if the market like
right now inflation's about to go up you
know goldman sachs we had a meeting with
them last week saying six did the last
time the interest rates went up twice in
a span of a quarter three months the uh
we had a recession within uh uh 24
months 60 chance there's been a
recession well we're in a recession
right now we're about to go through it
home property value is going to drop you
guys are seeing what's going on with
crypto what's going on with bitcoin
what's going with ethereum you can't
keep doing this they raised at a half a
point in the highest in the last four
decades this time is coming so how are
we prepared for it right this isn't oh
we're never gonna have another recession
oh we're never gonna have another
depression that's naive no it's coming
we're never going to have another hitler
we have to think
not we have to say there's going to be
one we have to say if there is
that's the only part i'm saying if a
country like a china or russia decides
to go out there and impose on around
their neighbors what are we going to be
i guess the the point that i think i i
was trying to get at before and i think
this is a bitter pill for a lot of
americans to to swallow
um
that if you're looking for someone
that's us right now yeah we're the ones
who have been that we have i mean if you
want to talk about the blood that
vladimir putin has on his head they make
this huge deal about when he invaded
crimea you know how many people died
when he invaded crimea six
six people died in the invasion of
crimea now in ukraine there have been it
looks like tens of thousands of people
dying and that's twenty three thousand
of his own people
it's horrible it's inexcusable i'm like
the most anti-war person on the planet
i'm not making any excuse for that
however it's just like
look
it doesn't always have to be hitler
exactly but there can be very very bad
people who kill a lot of people that was
a pretty unique thing hitler you like
gassing children and stuff that was
a unique evil maybe the most evil thing
in history but if you're looking at who
is the great evil right now
objectively speaking
we're sitting on the other side of this
this equation which is i think a bitter
pill to swallow from the inside of the
empire so my my perspective on that is
just like
look we got it like let's work on
rolling that evil back if there is a
hitler that rises up outside of the
united states of america some evil
person then yeah i agree with you there
should be contingencies in mind we
should be thinking about what can we do
to kind of have the whole world unite
against this unique evil if that were to
arise however
my only point that i keep kind of you
know harping on is that
we're probably we are definitely the
closest to that right now not us our
federal national government um and
this has been sold by
always invoking this guy's the next
hitler saddam hussein was the next
hitler and then gaddafi was the next
hitler and then assad is the next hitler
and then every single war that they want
they always tell you this guy is the
next hitler so i am just more concerned
i think in reality it's much more of an
issue the blood that our country has on
its hands right now and the fact that
this obsession with finding the next
hitler leads to claiming people who
could nev like the idea that that
qadhafi after decades of ruling this
country was about to go hitlerian
genocidal was complete nonsense and it's
basically been demonstrated at this
point that all the intelligence on that
was wrong and look at the result of that
you put qaddafi and putin in the same
camp that putin's not capable of doing
that no putin is
more capable yes they are more capable
than than but to deal with those people
you don't have to have a
military-industrial complex that's my
point if we i don't we're not saying
that though
no no nobody here is saying that at all
so complex to deal with the next hitler
whatever that next hitler is no you can
do it without the military industrial
complex hitler stalin and mao were left
well uh
hitler was a right-wing reactionary was
part of was the leader of a right-wing
reactionary movement stalin and mao were
leaders of the left-wing reactionary
movements actually lenin was and then
stalin took over but but mao was in
charge of the left-wing reactionary
movement in china these are reactions to
bad systems it wasn't like everything
was going great in those countries and
then mean old hitler stalin and mao
showed up where meanwhile uh
lenin hitler and mao showed up
we have to look at what leads to these
things happening and then fix that this
is like going to a doctor and you have
cancer and they go oh well you see you
got to burn there on your skin we're
going to deal with that well the burns
being caused by a cancer a systemic
problem that needs to be fixed and if
you don't deal with the cancer then
you're just going to keep dealing with
symptoms until the patient dies right we
have these are symptoms hitler was not
the problem he was a symptom of a
problem and what stalin and male were
not the symptoms they were the symptoms
of that problem the problem is a system
that benefits a very small handful of
people by design at everyone else's
expense that's why and that's why
libertarians focus so much on the
federal reserve and on the central
banking system and on things like that
it's that that leads to those yeah and
look even with the worst of all of them
mao se tang right i mean he has more
deaths on his hands than than adolf
hitler and joseph stalin combined and
look
richard nixon went over to china and
shook his hand and pat buchanan the most
right-wing you know guy you could think
of was writing speeches for him he said
pat buchanan literally said uh in his
book that he was making himself nauseous
and because he was nixon's speech writer
as he had to write these nice things
about mao zeita i mean imagine writing
nice things about the the most worst
human being who's ever existed on the
planet you know and but he did that and
that opened up relations and that was
better you know if i was thinking about
how to deal with a country like china or
like uh north korea or something like
that i'd be almost down for some like
guerrilla private organization to be
like we're smuggling dvds yes and like
internet hot spots into this country to
open it up so that's what they're
terrified of that's what north korea is
terrified of they're smuggling dvds from
from south korea and they start seeing
the south korean soap operas and they go
why do they have so much food on their
plates you've been telling us we're
richer than them what i've never seen
this much food you know what i mean it's
like that's the like the question
becomes like to spike's point what
caused this cancer and then what like
what is the cure for it yeah and the
short for it isn't
ussr wasn't anything militarily it was
freaking blue jeans yeah that's right
and movies it was that out and really
what is that that is a result of the
fact that our economic system of
capitalism even the kind of corrupt
capitalism that we had was superior to
their economic system and that they
ultimately wanted a good life like
americans were having right so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]